مثل المتهمون في القضيه التي عرفت اعلاميا
بطائره الذهب المشبوه مثل امام احدى محاكم
لوساكا عاصمه زامبيا وقررت المحكمه حبس
المتهمين احتياطيا رافضه الافراج عنهم
بكفاله من جهتها نقلت وكاله انباء الشرق
الاوسط الرسميه المصريه عن مصدر وصفته
بالمطلع قوله ان السلطات المصريه تنسق مع
نظيراتها الزامبيه وتتابع سلامه سير
اجراءات التحقيق معهم وكانت السلطات
الزامبيه اعلنت احتجاز طائره خاصه قادمه
من القاهره على متنها مبالغ ماليه بقيمه
نحو سته ملايين دولار
وسبائك قيل بدايه انها من الذهب قبل
الاعلان لاحقا انها معادن اخرى وقالت
السلطات الزامبيه انها وجهت للمتهمينه
تهمه التجسس ومن بينهم ضابط زامبي سابق في
مقاله وكاله الانباء الفرنسيه ان من بينهم
عسكريا مصريا سابقا
ووفقا لما اعلنه مدير لجنه مكافحه
المخدرات في زامبيا فان الموقوفين هم سته
مصريين واسباني وهولندي وزامبي ومواطن من
يواجه الموقوفون عقوبه السجن لمده تصل الى
30 عاما في حال ادانتهم
معنا من لوساكا عاصمه زامبيا
الفونسوكاسونغو الكاتب الصحفي والمحلل
السياسي مرحبا بك سيد الفونسو ماذا تقول
لنا هذه الاتهامات الموجهه بالنظر الى
طبيعه القضيه
مساء الخير نعم
لدينا هذه
الحادثه التي تدور حولها
ضغط كثير كبير
هناك بضاعه في علامتني تلك الطائره
في مطار لوساكا
نعم تفضل
وهناك عدد
من البضائع التي اوصلها التي تم اكتشافها
كميه من
سبائك الذهب
وايضا مبالغ ماليه نقديه
وهذه
والحكومه تقوم بتحقيق في هذا الامر
عن طريق وكاله
التهريب
اذا اليوم او بالامس
راينا
المتهمين الذين
تم العثور عليهم
وسيتم عرضهم على
المحاكم ونخشى
ان هؤلاء
المشبوهين
قد اخذوا الى المحاكم لانه لا يمكن ان
يحاكموا في بطرق اخرى سيد الفونسو السلطات
المصريه تقول انها تنسق مع السلطات في
زمبيا حول هذا الموضوع ما المعلومات حول
هذا التنسيق مع حدوده والى اين يمكن ان
يفضي
تنسيق قد يكون موجودا ولكن
الحكومه
الزامبيه هي التي تطبق القانون قانون
البلد
وينبغي ان تتم المحاكمه والنظر في هذه
القضيه من قبل السلطات الزامبيه
ونحن نسمع
ان هؤلاء المشبوهين
الذين من بينهم سته مصريين
وخمسه زمبيين
كانوا على علاقه
بالجوسسه او الاستخبارات والحكومه حريصه
على ان تطبق القانون
وحاله المشبوهين الى التحقيق والى
المحاكمه
شكرا لك
الكاتب الصحفي والمحلل السياسي ضيفنا من
لوساك عاصمه زامبيا